[Musique]
juste justement parce qu'il yad'autres
imac est ce qu on a vu
donc on a vu déjà cliqué c'est de
téléphone emmanuel macway ce que voulait
faire un pansement à l'autre qu'on vous
voulez être président j'ai dit ma fille
président est ce que voulait faire un
pas sans l'autre on à l'élysée avec
plaisir à les masser partie on appelle
l'elysée alors on rappelle le principe
alors on appelle une personne au hasard
le débat soit l'autre con chez la
personne passe une personne elle gagne
un cadeau très bien allez on y va alors
je rappelle que j'aidais françois
hollande ya une dizaine de jours c'est
vrai ils devaient m'inviter à manger
avant la fin du mandat
ouais il reste deux jours là un prénom
il restait rien pilar avant
l'investiture l'adulte prochain
président voilà donc je vous dis vous
avez un petit peu de temps quand il va
vous invitez c'est parti est ce qu'on a
fait est ce qu'on peut entendre la
sonnerie souple et bien il ya des frères
aussi tu arrives à 12 on est en train de
composer de la maison des gros doigts
oui c'est l'accueil de l'elysée c'est
parti attention il ya un cadeau pour la
personne s'offrir à elle seule personne
mais là j'en doute à la l'elysée s'est
passé d'un commissariat à l'eau
oui car ça va se faire voler haut
commissariat la place de la personne à
l'elysée en ce moment exact on va cadre
commissariat d'accord on va quelques
mètres et on serait très heureux est
d'offrir un cadeau à la personne à
l'heure où on a bien sûr on va passer
leurs pensions en votre âme et là elle
m'a laissée à l'eau oui parce que moi
l'autre con tu m'entends pardon c'est
michel actes et pas c'est qui oui je
sais bien trou du cul passe moi l'autre
qu'on dit c'est chaud là ouais nan
l'estrie mots je vais le faire face moi
l'autre con et je te reprends un prêt
pour vivre c'est quoi ton prénom lors qu
il peut gagner
il est bien mais bon on va lui faire un
cadeau du lycée passé mais un cadeau il
est très sympathique comment vous
appeler monsieur c'est cyril hanouna on
est en direct en touche pas à mon poste
[Musique]
[Rires]
merci et comment vous appelez ce que
selon vous offrir un smartphone au bond
se contredire à quoi et à la baisse à 1
dernière génération y les north une
maison de campagne
qu'est ce qui te fait plus c'est vrai
vous voulez quoi d'autre voulez quoi
vous voulez hein vous voulez vous voulez
une caméra sportive avec le smartphone
ouais vous laisse vous détaille tous les
cadeaux lance une bouteille de pastaga
allez va vous appeler pour un jeu comme
envisagé par un prénom à mon prénom
était sans voix la police alors d'accord
voilà
bonjour a tous fait un gros bisou salut
salut
[Applaudissements]
si longtemps wii passe moi l'autre con
non pas ce mois l'autre con oui même toi
le cul bonsoir
tu peux me passer s'il te plaît à
l'autre con tu sais très bien de qui je
veux parler mal q
[Applaudissements]
mais ça pendant qu'il essayait c'est de
la chance mais là c'était intense et
toitures au vide à laisser partir la
pelle koala les chéris sochaliens ont
rappelle non non non non non appel à
l'elysée ça leur a passé un temps qu'il
faut un truc qui marche à plein impôts
payés allez c'est parti à part avec eux
il y va c'est parti on appelle un
particulier lolo vous nous dites on
appelle qu'il en appelle quoi ce que
vous avez des numéros en régie ou est ce
que vous voulez je vous en donne le même
si vous dit à ma mère pas soit l'autre
quoi va dire il n'est pas la maison et
en émission ça rien commissariat de
guingamp comme sarriette guingamp allez
c'est parti on y va galgon qu'un quand
on embrasse tous les guingampais en
avant guingamp au stade du roudourou on
adore attention c'est parti
c'est le dernier passe moi le coin à
l'autre ah merci merci oui ça lui passe
quoi l'autre con je te plaît prends pas
ce mois l'autre con con way l'autre con
vite vite champlan que ce n'est qu'après
maintes tôles qui n'ont l'acheter
explique après midi tu crois qu'elle a 5
ans tu regardes autour de toi ça
t'inspire qui l'a tout de suite là il
est là ou pas il ya l'apéro a causé il
s'est enfermé dans son mutisme
en fait c'est laurent gaffié au
téléphone alors alors ad je dis mon nom
les gens accrochent barrière
le dira ce samedi à 21h c'est très très
fort stephen brun boulot merci à tous et
je vous lis je suis tu n'allais pas à
voter sans regarder le documentaire